- Oh my God, you look
like a (bleep) smurf.
- Hey, guys, what's up?
This wasn't supposed to be a video.
I literally just whipped out my phone.
What happened was I've had a Jew-fro
for basically my entire life.
Today, I went to get a haircut,
decided to do something new,
and now, I'm literally too
scared to walk into the office.
Now, I'm not a shy person or anything.
I've literally come to the office
wearing nothing but body paint.
For some reason,
my hair's something that
is stressing me out,
like I literally can't walk
into the office right now.
I'm gonna have my buddy, Ade,
he's gonna bring me a hat
so I can cover my hair
and then see what people
think of my new hair.
It's different.
I look very different.
I'm waiting for Ade right
now, and this is awkward.
Alright.
Thank you, Ade, for bringing the hat.
I look weird with a hat.
I look like a weird sperm, like a fetus.
(crying)
Okay, so I got my friend to record me.
I'm gonna walk around the office
and see what people think
of this new haircut.
(exhales sharply)
(intense music)
- What's up?
- I need your help.
- Okay.
- You have good hair.
- Yes.
- You love it.
- Okay.
- Did you do something to your hair?
- Did you think I needed a haircut?
- Yes, it looked awful.
- Okay, Brenda, what
do you usually think of
when you think of my hair?
- I always think curly,
pretty, healthy, very cute.
So...
- Cute?
- Oh, yeah, your hair...
Have you seen it?
It's so cute, yeah.
Every girl loves curls.
- I want your 100% honest
feedback on this new hairstyle.
- Okay.
- Alright.
Close your eyes.
Okay, look good?
Alright.
- Three, two, one.
That's...
- Oh.
- No, dude.
No.
Top knots are so 2016.
- What?
Is that what you're
gonna do with your hair?
- Yeah, this is the new me.
- You're gonna walk around with that?
(laughing)
You're not walking around with that.
- What other option do I have?
- It's not even a real top
bun, like why is it right here?
It should be...
- Where is it supposed to be?
- Further in the back.
- I don't know how to do it.
- That's strugglin' to be...
(mumbling)
- I feel like a viking or something.
- (laughs) A baby viking.
- My ponytail still hasn't
gone through puberty, you know?
It's still, it's a micro-ponytail.
- Is this the Ariana Grande look for men?
- Right, she had the bun.
Everyone loves Ariana Grande.
- Not on you, man.
(gagging)
(laughing)
No, please, go back to the curls.
- What do I do?
I can't go back to the curls.
- [Brenda] What do you mean you can't?
- It's over.
- It's over?
- It's gone.
- You chopped your hair?
- Yeah.
- I don't like it.
I think it takes away
from what makes you you.
- Thank you.
I'm gonna go home now and cry
and high-five myself because...
- I didn't know if that
was just a wave goodbye.
- So, what do I do?
What's your advice?
'Cause I can't walk around
the office like this.
- You ever heard of extensions?
- Like a full ponytail?
- Yeah.
- How long would it take to grow it out?
- If I had to give an educated guess,
seven to eight weeks to
get another couple inches.
- That sounds like what
my doctor used to tell me.
(laughing)
I could dye the rest of my hair gray
so it looks like a bomb.
So, this is the little
whisk that you light.
- You know, and it's commentary.
- On today's society.
- On today.
- So, keep this, right?
Embrace it.
- Listen, you only live once.
- That's what my barber said this morning.
- I would cut it.
- Just cut it off?
- Yeah.
- You want me to cut it off?
- Wanna, yeah, just cut it,
cut it off.
- Shut up.
Eric, you do not want me to cut your hair.
- I need you to just
cut it off, immediately.
- Eric, look at me in the eyes
and tell me to cut it off.
- No, don't cut it off.
- Can you take that out?
- I don't know what happens.
- Let's see.
(sultry jazz music)
(laughing)
- Look how concerned Sabrina looks.
- I am really concerned for you.
(laughing)
- Jesus Christ.
He looks like one of those troll dolls.
I love that this is on hand.
Is it not the same?
- That's so not cool.
Eric, go back, get your money.
This is so bad, it's so bad.
I'm sorry.
You know I'm honest, I can't (bleep) you.
You look like (bleep) right like that.
- Jesus Christ.
I still have the Jew-fro on top, okay?
It never went away,
I just don't have the Jew-fro on the side.
Help me.
I mean, maybe somethin' like this.
Is this good?
Usually these videos have
some sort of positive ending,
like I've learned to love my hair
and I've learned to love what I have.
What I learned is...
I don't know what the
lesson is, I don't know.
You know what?
I've always wanted a mohawk as
a kid, and now I've tried it.
So, check that off the bucket list.
Looks how it's moving, like a living...
It's like Jello on my hair
or a freakin' fish wobblin' up there.
I'm not scared to do
anything to my hair anymore.
You can try whatever you want,
and even if you fail as majorly as this,
it literally does not matter.
There's always time to
explore, discover who you are,
and have fun with it.
Let me know in the comments below
if you've ever tried anything
new with your style or hair
and it went terribly wrong.
(upbeat music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new
channel, and now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.